was zum kuckuck ist das ein deutsches
kulturgut in xxl
das ist die größte kuckucks oder welt
und sie vereint all das wofür die
kuckucksuhr weltweit bekannt ist
präzisionsarbeit handwerk und eine
leidenschaft für den kuckuck für einen
kokon warum in aller welt eingeschrieben
kuckuck der schwarzwald die wiege der
kuckucksuhren
die region im südwesten deutschlands ist
ein zentrum der europäischen uhrmacher
tradition gut 100 kilometer von
stuttgart entfernt liegt triberg rund um
das kleine städtchen wird anfang des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts jede dritte uhr
auf der welt hergestellt und heute jede
original schwarzwälder kuckucksuhr eine
davon ist die größte kuckucksuhr der
welt die eu nimmt ein ganzes haus ein
und ist begehbar fünf jahre lang haben
zwei uhrmacher an dem vier meter fünfzig
mal vier meter fünfzig großen
mechanischen uhrwerk herumgetüftelt 1994
war es fertig weltrekord und eine
technische meisterleistung wie mir der
vorsitzende des vereins die
schwarzwalduhr erklärt ich würde ich ein
uhrwerk das jetzt seit hunderten jahren
letztendlich verbaut wird es alles
original dass ich irgendwie mini
motorräder vorangetrieben des gewichts
antrieb es ist wirklich spektakulär weil
es eben dieses kleine kleine uhrwerk
neben in serie gebaut wurde
die typische schwarzwälder kuckucksuhr
ist hand geschnitzt und hat die form
eines bauernhauses
erfunden hat sie ein uhrmacher namens
franz anton ketterer im achtzehnten
jahrhundert zu derzeit werden im
schwarzwald schon fleißig uhren aus holz
hergestellt
landwirte fertigen die zeitmesser in den
langen wintermonaten als nebenerwerb am
heimischen küchentisch viele uhrmacher
blicken auf diese familientradition
zurück ingolf haas fertigt hier in
vierter generation kuckucksuhren seit
125 jahren alles per hand
international sind vor allem die
klassischen modelle gefragt muss ich
immer wieder sage guck wird die löst so
viel emotionen also bei mir ist ja noch
viel mehr ersten hineingeboren
also ich bin praktisch ich habe schon in
die wiege eine kurve kriegte ungefähr da
hängt nämlich noch viel mehr
auch herzblut mit granja ich sagt
manchmal witziger weise ich glaube mein
herz schlägt kuckuck 2005 ist es für
ingolf haas an der zeit die
kuckucksuhren welt auf den kopf zu
stellen
er entwirft moderne varianten und kunst
editionen die haben natürlich als genial
bezeichnet
auch für andere seiten hansen schläge
angedroht er könnte es machen das ist
die crux juli darf nicht verändern und
die haben uns beleidigt also es gab
überall in den ersten jahren gab es
wirklich wir haben einige ausstellungen
gemacht es gab beleidigungen das könnt
ihr euch gar nicht vorlegen viele
prominente kunden sind jedenfalls
begeistert ob wladimir putin prinz
william oder david hasselhoff sie alle
besitzen eine kuckucksuhr
das beliebteste modell eine moderne
variante bei der man sehen kann wie zwei
blase bilde die pfeiftöne erzeugen warum
eigentlich ein kuckuck an und caterer
wollte eigentlich entwickler aus diesem
grund bauen die kikeriki gemacht hätten
und habe aber diesen hahnenschrei
mechanisch nicht hingekriegt und
zufällig hat er doch eben diese beiden
genommen diese blase präge und da war
das aber kein kikeriki das gehe eben
nicht sondern es war kuckuck jetzt weiß
ich dass der beliebte deutsche
exportschlager durch einen zufall
entstanden ist ich finde sie toll sie
sind niedlich
ich bewundere die handwerksarbeit hier
gibt es einige der schönsten exemplare
ich hätte nie gedacht das ist so viele
unterschiedliche kuckucksuhren gibt und
in welcher leidenschaft den menschen
hier die tradition der kuckucksuhr
fortführen hat mich wirklich beeindruckt
mein herz schlägt jetzt auch schon ein
bisschen gucken
[Musik]